[Music]  none of us really know each other her  all screw-ups but somehow we were all in  the same place at the same time when  Billy Fowler's coins  gosh she tell how we glow Oh black what  I say nice try  the answer to what is happening to you  is here you five are the Power Rangers  did I just use they were Power Rangers  this I'm gonna joke we're talking to a  wall I was kind of expecting a little  more so where were you last night  me and four kids found a spaceship  buried underground I'm pretty sure I'm a  superhero cool pin that Cup Power  Rangers were a legion of warriors you  must become those warriors it's the  hologram like a video game  she is pure evil  party expect us to starboard  it's morphin time so we're better than  anybody ever seen  [Music]  it's a lot of gold  this is your destiny  this is your time  you